I feel like we should have like applause
and confetti but we've been up there was
a lot of that out there congratulations
thank you done well you're kind of done
you still have to talk to us but that's
okay this is the easy part of a party
yeah you seemed very very cool I
mentioned that to you when we were on
the red carpet there you seemed very
chill and together before you were
getting up to do that and thank you said
before you get a little bit nervous
about those things yeah and you seem
even chill right now really it's over
yeah maybe that's why I'm tell me
because I know that I didn't fail but
yeah it was it was crazy I tried my best
to just be collected and relaxed went on
yeah it was it was crazy the adrenaline
I think is what kept me Hannah energetic
it's good right we just had that Joe and
DNC in here and Joe said he thought that
he screwed up a bunch of times in
rehearsal but that the actual live show
went really well yeah yeah your dirty
dirty liar did he do okay he did amazing
he's been for the natural like he's been
performing forever he used to act and
stuff so yeah you have it down yeah I
think we're all just felt critical right
it was it nicer to be I mean you're a
part of the whole thing I mean sometimes
you had shows like this you kind of get
dropped in for a minute and then you're
gone you're weaved in and woven into the
whole thing was it kind of nice to be a
part of it it really wild level yeah it
was totally different like from me
usually like you said it's like in and
out you perform and you leave but this
time it was like wardrobe changes I've
never done that whole thing before like
reading from a prompter it was all very
like different to me but I loved it I
had a great time
I'm did I know the hair that changes and
stuff like got their streaks in the hair
and I've led to believe that you have a
family member who takes care of your
hair for you yes my mother I don't know
she is she's hiding she was helping you
was she following you around making sure
that before you went on every time yeah
she always eats when my hair is messy so
she's always like come back I gotta
spray it more she every like and when
she's not here and I do my own hair for
event she like yeah I think she goes
crazy she's like what are you doing
you're so pretty here when you're when
you're working on new music obviously
stays doing so well right now and
platinum and everything and all the
accolades that are coming with that song
does that that change the direction I
know you're working on the music right
now I think you said 12 tracks are we
I've written them out know if any of
them are going to end up on a I don't
know if anything we're going to end up I
hope so I mean a few I like a lot of
them but I want to keep writing more
into just and then like reevaluate all
of them
so does it's a work in progress right
I'm assuming the success of stay might
affect the direction the rest of the
songs take um you know what I mean
sonically no I think I do
know that I would be like as gold to do
that type or genre on my own music so
that's why I didn't want to collab yeah
I don't know I don't think that's really
my soul like for a whole album unless I
would do all like dance tracks because I
don't typically write that way I write
more like RB mark soulful I guess um oh
yeah I I don't know I it's so early on
in the process that I don't really know
what the sound is yet it's sounding
pretty cool so far like I have a cool
vibe there's a there's an opportunity to
events like this to bump into people to
rub elbows with people that you might
not necessarily see on a day-to-day
basis and maybe they say some some kind
words to you - have you had have you had
that happen maybe even if it wasn't at
this event but at another event where
you bumped into somebody you haven't met
before and they just said something to
you about your music the way it affected
them or something like really kind of
blew your mind a little bit all the time
which is amazing even get to say that
yeah that sounded really you know I mean
like it's it's so awesome to like look
up to somebody for so long and be a fan
because I'm such a music fan and then
you know all of a sudden becoming a peer
of these people and then have them tell
you that their fan it's like amazing I
just met Lord today I'm like I listened
to her album religiously her first album
so crazy to just you know be in the same
places who are doing the same thing and
have her say that she likes what I do -
it's often a bit of a mind blower right
yeah it's crazy it's awesome that's cool
would you do this kind of thing again
would you come back and hope because you
know guys like maybe a TV hosts really
like it when musicians take over hosting
gigs really you know what I mean
that's the yeah it's a different you
guys are nothing I think yeah I don't
know I mean there's a tape of me saying
at the last year's red carpet that I
would never host because I would be too
nervous and I'm here so I could be back
again I don't know what's gonna happen
but I don't know it might be a one-time
thing I might want to do this the one
time you've made an emotional
breakthrough either way though you
thought you'd be too nervous in your
weren't you did it you're not get out of
the place yeah congratulations thank you
race John thanks for